(upbeat music)
- I just don't understand,
if you're the one who
overbooked the hotel,
- This is crazy.
- you usually accommodate the
people that you screwed over,
- Right?
- by finding them places to stay, but no.
- I just couldn't believe
it when you called me.
I thought to myself--
- Happy Valentine's Day.
Oh.
Hey.
- Babe?
Uh.
Hi.
Oh my God.
Wow.
I didn't think we were
doing anything this year,
for Valentine's.
- We weren't, but I
thought I'd change it up.
I don't know.
- I know that.
I just thought we had agreed
to take things at face value,
to not (stammering).
Sorry, this is Kate,
- Hey.
- Nice to meet you.
- from college.
- Oh yeah.
- Kate had some travel mishaps.
- They overbooked my hotel.
It was this whole thing.
- So I said she could stay here tonight.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause this is what we
talked about, beforehand.
- We talked about Kate staying over?
- Yeah, I mean, doing nothing.
Not doing anything tonight.
- Right.
Not doing anything is the
same as having your friend
stay the night over, right?
- Listen.
Hey, you guys are doing something.
I think I could get one
of those pod chairs.
- No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
- I'm sure pod chairs
are super open right now.
- It's just another day.
I'll cancel all my plans.
I don't care.
- I think it would be better if I just--
- No, no, no, no, no.
You're staying.
Please.
I insist.
- You're staying.
- Come on.
Okay.
So you definitely can
add a third wheel to our,
a third party to our reservation?
I know it's Valentine's
Day (chuckling), but,
I'd be laughing too if
I were you honestly.
Cancellation fee?
Even if I don't eat I
still have to pay $250?
Well, I,
Look, I'm not gonna
shoot the messenger here,
I mean, that's a fair price.
Alright, well, thank you anyway.
- So babe, what'd they have to say?
- It's lookin' like it's
gonna be a little tough
to squeeze in a third.
- Did you talk to, did
you talk to the manager?
- Why don't you two go together?
- Oh, no, um.
- We cannot let this
reservation go to waste.
- Well, I don't--
- This is like a once in a lifetime meal.
- Why don't?
You know, you know,
you've been so excited
about this restaurant.
- You two.
Girls night out.
While I sit here alone on Valentine's Day.
- My shoes are already off.
- You know what?
(clear throat)
I'm actually pretty tired,
and I have to work early in the morning,
so I'm just gonna turn in.
I'm just gonna.
(fingers snapping)
- She's tired.
- Tired?
- Yeah.
- Alright.
Let's get you tucked in.
Come on Ben.
How could I have not predicted
you were gonna have a friend
in town on Valentine's night?
- Babe, can I help you?
- No, I got this.
- Are you sure?
- No.
This is my mess.
I'm gonna live in it.
I'm gonna clean it.
- Ha ha.
- I'm gonna fold it.
- I think I'm gonna run
down to Waffle House,
and just hang out there for a little bit.
- Waffle House?
- I'll be back in like in a good--
- What are you, hungry?
I'll set you up with some food.
Come on.
We got food here.
Let's go.
- I'm, it's less,
(whimsical music)
(laughs nervously)
- Wow.
You know, If I had known we
had guests coming over tonight,
I probably would have done a
little bit of grocery shoppin',
'cause we got nada.
- Babe.
- Yogurt?
Babe.
- Looks like we got medium egg noodles,
- Babe.
- for dinner.
You like egg noodles?
We got peanut butter.
- Babe, why don't I.
Can I help you get in there?
- So hey, you took your shoes off.
You're off duty for the rest of the night.
- You know?
- They put peanut sauce on Thai stuff.
We'll do a little Pad Thai.
- You know what?
I'm just gonna hop in.
- Maybe put some yogurt too.
Get a little creamy al dente.
- I'm just gonna hop in.
- Hey!
- All this nonsense that's on the floor,
that nobody really asked for.
- You like carrots?
- Behind you.
Okay.
- Valentine's Day tradition.
Us three.
Get together every year.
- Yeah.
- I am actually happier
eating here right now.
- Me too, actually.
Me too.
- You know what I like?
Fine, nice thin cut shichimi.
- Hm.
- Probably the best
Valentine's Day I've ever had.
(spraying can)
- Ahh!
- Ow!
- Oh my God!
I got bleach in my eye!
- Oh, I really cut deep here, you guys--
- I can't believe.
Fuck.
- Guys!
Guys!
Look at yourselves.
This is 100 % the most
dysfunctional relationship
I've ever seen in my life.
This is hard to watch.
You guys just should,
this is,
unhealthy.
You should not be together.
Look at you.
- I am so sorry.
- No. It's,
- I'm sorry that we,
I mean we open our house to you,
on Valentine's Day, and
- We let you into our house.
- We were cooking you a
meal on Valentine's Day.
- What?
You're gonna tell us how
to live our relationship.
Says the girl who's
single on Valentine's Day.
- Poor Ben was trying to find you--
The nerve.
- Kate, I haven't seen you in years.
- I gotta go.
- What's this?
I gotta.
- You gotta go.
- Alright.
- Yeah, have fun out there.
(door closes)
God, we're lucky.
- Yeah.
You got that right.
- Hmm.
- I love you.
- I love you too.
Happy Valentine's Day.
- Happy Valentine's Day.
- I need to go to the hospital.
(upbeat music)